350.000 Quadratkilometer fast genauso
groß wie Deutschland
das größte Korallenriff der Erde
UNESCO Weltnaturerbe
ein Schatz der seinesgleichen sucht
ein Schatz den wir zu verlieren drohen
Great Barrier Reef
Mission Rettung des Riffs aims das
Australian Institute of marine science
ist das Maß aller Dinge hier stemmt sich
die Wissenschaft gegen den Kollaps der
Natur Annika lamp Mitte 20
Meeresbiologin forscht hier mit
absoluter Begeisterung
jeden Tag muss ich mich damit
auseinandersetzen was diesem Ökosystem
angetan wird dass ich so sehr liebe aber
das nimmt mir nicht die Hoffnung wenn
ich das Great Barrier Reef sehe da wo es
gesund und wunderschön ist dann weiß ich
nur unser Einsatz lohnt sich also ich
habe Hoffnung aber wir müssen was dafür
tun
in den unzähligen Becken simulieren sie
die Lebensbedingungen am Riff Korallen
sind sensible Geschöpfe und das
Fundament des Ökosystems sie bieten
Lebensraum sich an Artenvielfalt die
Forscher dokumentieren jeden
Entwicklungsschritt Wasserqualität
Lichteinfall Temperaturen was passiert
wenn sich diese Lebensbedingungen ändern
wenn es ungemütlicher wird für die
Bewohner des Riffs
suchen zu züchten die widerstandsfähig
sind die unter hohen Temperaturen
überleben die Idee ist diese Korallen am
Riff anzusiedeln damit sich das
Ökosystem dauerhaft erholt unter den
sich ändernden klimabedingten
asianer sich weiter Aufheizen
der größte Stressfaktor für das Great
Barrier Reef ist die zunehmende
Häufigkeit solcher Hitzeperioden
Korallenbleiche ist das Phänomen dass
sie fürchten und dass sie in den
vergangenen Jahren zu oft durchlitten
haben wird das Wasser zu warm stößt die
Koralle Algen ab dieser Algen Bewuchs
aber sorgt nicht nur für prächtige
Farben sondern versorgt die Koralle auch
mit Nährstoffen kommen die alten nicht
zurück geht die Koralle zu Grunde
und diese Auswirkungen lassen sich
direkt auf uns Menschen zurückführen
ja leider ist das so
manipulieren die natürlichen
Lebensbedingungen in eine Richtung die
den Organismen mehr und mehr Stress
bringt
diese Richtung hat einen Namen
Klimawandel Australien spürt ihn heftig
zu Wasser und zu Land da ist die Hitze
die Dürre Trockenheit verlorene ernten
apokalyptische Bilder von brennenden
Wäldern dann wieder stehen Städte Dörfer
ganze Landschaften komplett unter Wasser
die Extreme sind normal geworden
beängstigend nennt das die
Umweltschützerin Crystal folknau
ich meine die Botschaft ist sowas von
klar und mit jeder Katastrophe wird sie
noch klarer so traurig ist auch ist dass
manche Menschen und Regierungen solche
Ereignisse brauchen um endlich die Augen
zu öffnen
immer ist die Rede davon was es uns
kostet wenn wir uns umstellen müssen
unsere Wirtschaft umbauen und so aber
langsam erkennen wir doch was es uns
wirklich kostet wenn wir nicht handeln
nirgends scheint das deutlicher als am
Great Barrier Reef vier Korallen
bleichen in sechs Jahren mit Schäden so
massiv dass die UNESCO droht den Titel
Welt Naturerbe abzuerkennen es geht um
Australiens guten Ruf und viel Geld das
Riff ist ein enormer Wirtschaftsfaktor
70.000 Arbeitsplätze die meisten im
Tourismus
die Rostockerin Nadine Huth kam vor neun
Jahren hängte dafür ihren sicheren
Beamtenjob an den Nagel am Riff zu
arbeiten und zu leben für Nadine das
große Los
geworden und für mich die Nähe zum Meer
auf dem Wasser zu sein eben Wasser zu
sein ich bin auch Tauchlehrer also ich
kann es nie erwarten
Faszination Riff da ist sie wieder
Nadine sagt wenn die Touristen sie auch
spüren dann sei etwas gewonnen das
Verständnis dieses Paradies zu schützen
Nadine und ihre Kollegen selbst tauchen
auch im Auftrag der Wissenschaft
ja Schnorcheln in unterschiedlichen
Tiefen um zu gucken wie viele Korallen
sind da vor Ort wie viele
unterschiedliche Typen von Korallen für
Korallen sind abgestorben wie viel Alben
sind dort
ob Korallenbleiche vorliegt oder nicht
die gesammelten Daten schicken sie an
die Meeresbiologen des ems-instituts zu
schließt sich ein Kreis der engagierten
derer die nicht zusehen wollen wie ein
einzigartiges Ökosystem zugrunde geht
den Mut zu behalten nicht immer leicht
vor allen Dingen weil ich so lange hier
schon arbeite und die Veränderung
hautnah sehen kann ist es äh sehr
frustrierend weil man auch weiß was man
als als kleine Person schon machen kann
aber natürlich muss das Land Länder die
Welt damit ziehen um den Klimawandel
entgegen zu sprechen
Great Barrier Reef wer es gesehen hat
den Pakt ist der kann nicht wollen dass
es vergeht der muss etwas tun
[Musik]